شكرا
للزميله نادين خماش اهلا بكم الى ساعه
اخباريه مفصله نخصص معظمها لتطورات المشهد
السوداني ونبداها كالعاده بالعنوي
الجيش السوداني يقول ان البلاد ورثت ثقيلا
لخطا النظام السابق في تشكيل الدعم السريع
رغم الهدنه الجديده بين طرفي النزاع
بالسودان اشتباكات متقطعه وادوي انفجارات
جنوبي الخرطوم
دخول نحو خمسه عشر الف سودانيين لمصر عبر
المنافذ البريه والقاهره تنسق مع الجيش
السوداني لاجلاء العالقين
في هذه الساعه ايضا
مئات الالاف يتظاهرون في فرنسا ضد قانون
اصلاح نظام التقاعد
[موسيقى]
قبل التفاصيل نبدا بهذه الاخبار
العاجله مشاهدينا نتابع قبلها صور من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مباشره
لتصاعد اعمده الدخان من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم التي تدخل اليوم هدنه سادسه لمده
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه ابرز الاخبار العاجله
حيث قال المبعوث الاممي للسودان
سنعمل على تامين وقف اطلاق النار برقابه
وطنيه والدوليه قال بان الجيش والدعم
السريع وفق على ارسال مندوبين للتفاوض
المبعوث الاممي ايضا اضاف بان المفاوضات
ستركز على وقف اطلاق النار بشكل مستمر
وموثوقه بانه سيعمل على تامين وقف اطلاق
النار برقابه وطنيه ودوليه وبان المفاوضات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع ستعقد في
السعوديه على الارجح اضاف ايضا بانه يواجه
معوقات في اقناع طرفي الصراع بانهاء العنف
هذه اذا ابرز واخر الاخبار العاجله
القادمه من السودان مع متابعه يعني مستمره
لهذه الصور من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
تصاعد اعمده الدخان حتى هذه اللحظه مع
دخول الهدنه السادسه حيز التنفيذ منذ
الثانيه عشره منتصف الليل البارحه
المبعوث الامي اذا كما ذكرنا قال بان هناك
مفاوضات بين الجيش والدعم السريع قريبه
ستعقد في السعوديه على الارجح
الجيش السوداني مشاهدينا قال ان البلاد
ورثت عبء ثقيلا لخطا النظام السابق في
تشكيل الدعم السريع واكد الجيش في بيان ان
الاوضاع حاليا تشهد هدوءا حذرا وهي مستقره
في جميع ولايات البلاد وبحسب البيان حشدت
قوات الدعم السريع اكثر من 65 الف عنصر
والفي مركبه للهجوم على الخرطوم قبل
الخامس عشر من ابريل لكن الجيش استطاع
التصدي لمحاولات انتشارهم مشيرا الى ان
الجيش تمكن في غضون اسبوعين من القتال ان
يخفض من قدرات الدعم السريع القتاليه الى
النصف مضيفا انه تم احباطه عده تحركات
لتعزيزات عسكريه لقوات الدعم السريع قادمه
من اتجاه الغربي الى الخرطوم
هذا وتواصل وحدات الجيش السوداني اجراء
عمليات تمشيط في منطقه الخرطوم بحري بينما
تستمر الاشتباكات المتقطعه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في مناطق متفرقه بالعاصمه
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
قبل ذلك نشر الجيش السوداني لقطات لقائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان وهو يشرف على
سير العمليات العسكريه من احد مراكز
القياده
[موسيقى]
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحه في عماره
بوشاب عمار مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه
قبل قليل كنا ان نتابع صور تصاعد لاعمده
الدخان من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم التي
تعيش هدنه منذ منتصف ليله البارحه هل يعني
ذلك عوده الاشتباكات من جديد في العاصمه
الخرطوم
نعم هذه الاعمده المتصاعده للدخان هي من
مدينه بحري حيث تحدثنا الى عدد من المصادر
الميدانيه التي اشارت الى تجدد الاشتباكات
في منطقه كافوري وفي المنطقه الصناعيه
بحري وهذه المنطقه تحوي عدد كبير جدا من
المصانع وعدد كبير جدا من الاحياء السكنيه
في منطقه كافوري وهنالك تتحصل القوات
الدعم السريع منذ اليوم الاول للحرب
والجيش من خلال عده بيانات ومن خلال عده
عمليات عسكريه اشار الى بدايه عمليه
التمشيط في المنطقه ما يعني ان هنالك
اشتباكا او مواجهات مباشره على ارض
المعركه الان تجري في تلك المنطقه وقبل
قليل كنا نستمع الى عدد من
الرصاصات وعدد من الاشتباكات المتقطعه هنا
في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم في محيط مطار
الخرطوم وفي محيط القياده العامه للجيش
هذه الاشتباكات تاتي بالتزامن مع الحديث
والذي نشر قبل قليل والمعلومات التي تسربت
عن موافقه الطرفين على بدايه حوار هو
تسويه سياسيه ربما يعني تجري في الايام
والساعات القادمه ربما كل طرف يحاول ان
يثبت
يحاول ان يتحرك اكثر على ارض الميدان وعلى
ارض المعركه حتى حينما يدخل الطرفان الى
عمليه التفاوض يكن قبل قبل عمليه التفاوض
عمار سنه الجيش سناتي عليها لكن نريد ان
نسال ميدانيا الان منذ متى بدات هذه
الاشتباكات يعني كان هناك هدوء يسود
الخرطوم وايضا حتى المحافظات التابعه لها
وايضا كذلك بالنسبه لعمليات التمشيط اين
تركزت وهل بدا سماع ذوي اطلاق الرصاص مع
بدايه التمشيط ام قبل ذلك
نعم بدات هذه ربما العمليات قبل اكثر من
ساعه ونصف
ولاحظنا ذلك من خلال سماع العديد من
رصاصات والاشتباكات وربما المدافع التي لم
نكن نستمع اليها في الايام السابقه وربما
ايضا استخدام مضادات الطيران وكان هنالك
التحليق حربي لدقائق قبل ساعه ونصف من
الان هذه الاشتباكات تجددت في هذه المنطقه
وهذه المنطقه ربما تعني بعدا استراتيجيا
مهما جدا خاصه وانها تطل على مناطق شرق
النيل ومن خلالها تتحصن قوات الدعم السريع
ولها امتدادات في هذه المنطقه مما يعني ان
الجيش قد بدا عمليه تمشيط في هذه المنطقه
محاوله لكسب مزيد من الاراضي ومحاوله لكسب
مزيد من النقاط على الارض ما يجعل عمليات
خنق قوات الدعم السريع داخل العاصمه بحسب
بيان الجيش وبحسب الحديث عن تدمير اكثر من
45 الى
55% من قدراتها القتاليه هذه العمليات
ربما اثرت بشكل كبير جدا على الطرقات في
تلك المنطقه وعلى السكان الذين ما زالوا
يتواجدون في تلك المناطق ولم يخرجوا اسوه
بالذين خرجوا من تلك المناطق الى مناطق
امنه اكثر مما كانت عليه المناطق الاخرى
تحدثنا ايضا الى مصادر محليه وميدانيه في
تلك المناطق اشارت الى ان عمليات
الاشتباكات هي عمليات كر وفر وعمليات ايضا
متصاعده ما بين فتره واخرى ونلاحظ هذه
الحرائق وهذه الاعمده المتصاعده للدخان
والتي تشير الى ان هنالك ربما اليات او
ربما مقر او ربما مصانع او ربما منازل قد
تدمرت وقد احترقت وما زالت تتصاعد منها
اعمده الدخان طيب على الارض في الخرطوم
بحري اريد ان اسال عن عن السيطره عن ايضا
كذلك الانتشار يعني حسب سير المعارك في
الخرطوم بحري منذ
بدايتها كيف تبدو عمار ميدانيا
هذه المدينه انقسمت الى نصفين يعني منذ او
اذا ما حسبناها من اتجاه كوبري جسر
الحلفايه او كبر الحلفايه باتجاه احياء
بحر القديم وباتجاه منطقه الشرق النيل
وباتجاه منطقه المنطقه الجنوبيه والغربيه
ربما تتحصن قوات الدعم السريع ولها
معسكرات في معسكر المظلات في الجانب
الغربي ولها معسكرات ايضا في جانب كافوري
الجانب الشرقي بالاتجاه الشمالي الشمال
مدينه بحرب اذا ما ذهبنا الى بعض جسر
حلفايه لذلك انتشار واسع لقوات القوات
الشعب المسلحه قوات الجيش في تلك المناطق
وانتشرت بشكل لافت وبدات تمشيطا فعليا في
تلك المنطقه هذه المنطقه التي انقسمت الى
نصفين هنالك مرتكزات اساسيه ما بين
المنطقه الغربيه الشرقيه والمنطقه
الشماليه وهي عمليه الدخول بين فتره واخرى
للجيش وعمليه الاسترجاع مره اخرى لقوات
نعم يعني كثير من المستشفيات وكثير من
المقر الصحيه تحدثت الينا ونشرت فيها
الكثير من الفيديوهات خاصه في المدينه
ربما يعني لم تتضرر بسبب القصف او ربما
بالاشتباكات المتبادله لكن ربما التضرر
اكبر كان يكون في صعوبه الوصول للكوادر
الطبيه الى تلك المستشفيات وصعوبه الوصول
لتلك المناطق التي ربما تقع فيها اشتباكات
مباشره وفيها عدد من الارتكازات على مستوى
الشوارع وايضا عمليه امداد تلك المناطق من
المنطقه الشماليه الى المنطقه الشرقيه
والغربيه
والمنطقه الجنوبيه يبدو صعبا في عمليه
الوصول لا سيما وان محطه مياه مدينه بحري
تقع في المنطقه اقصى المنطقه الجنوبيه وفي
كثير من البيانات التي نشرت من هيئه مياه
ولايه الخرطوم اشارت الى انها يصعب الوصول
لتلك المناطق لوجود اشتباكات لعدم وجود
ممرات امنه في تلك المناطق وهذه
المستشفيات تعتمد بشكل كبير على الماء
وتعتمد تعتمد بشكل كبير على الكهرباء
والتي ايضا تنقطع لفترات طويله جدا في تلك
المنطقه ويصعب حتى ايصال عدد من الوقود او
المحروقات لتشغيل هذه المستشفيات في تلك
المناطق اما في مدينه بحري في الجانب
الشمالي ما زالت عدد من المستشفيات تعمل
هنالك مستشفيات ومراكز صحيه دخلت الى
الخدمه اليوم كمركز الى الخدمه اليوم بعدد
كافي لعدد من المرضى الذين اتوا لتلك
المقر الصح اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات التي اطلعتنا عليها من الخرطوم
بحري الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه
ومع استمرار المواجهات ظهر العشرات امام
البيت الابيض في العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن
لمطالبه السلطات الامريكيه التدخل لوقف
القتال في السودان بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يواجه الكثير من السودانيين مصاعب حقيقيه
في ممارسه حياتهم اليوميه بسبب الاقتتال
الدائري بين الجيش والدعم السريع حيث
يواجه عمال الاجره اليوميه معاناه مع
استمرار الاشتباكات حيث اختفت فرص العمل
بسبب الحرب
فتره الطول الحرب بنيه شغل لكن معاناته
والله بامانه كده يعني حكايه ظرف صعب جدا
جدا العمل متوقف
جاءت الحروب
ده بالنسبه لمحل انا ذليت 3000
والله
مشاهدينا نتابع واياكم هذا الفيديو
المتداول من الخرطوم بحري تصاعد اذا
لاعمده الدخان في الخرطوم بحري تاكيدا
طبعا لما نقله مراسل العربيه قبل قليل
بتجدد الاشتباكات في كافوري والمنطقه
الصناعيه كذلك بالخرطوم بحري او هذا
الفيديو الذي نتابعه الان
الخاص بالعربيه اذا لتصاعد اعمده الدخان
من الخرطوم بحري وكما ذكرنا قبل قليل واكد
مراسل العربيه بان هناك تجدد للاشتباكات
في كفوري والمنطقه الصناعيه كذلك بالخرطوم
بحري وكما ذكرنا بان السودان يدخل في هدنه
سادسه لمده اثنتين وسبعين ساعه لكن
الاشتباكات تتجدد مره اخرى في الخرطوم
بحري تحديدا في المنطقه الصناعيه ايضا
كذلك كما نشاهد هذا
الفيديو مشاهدينا من الخرطوم بحري الفيديو
الذي تنفرد به العربيه طبعا في تغطيتها
المستمره للاحداث في السودان تصعد اعمده
الدخان دون انقطاع كما نشاهد الان على
شاشه العربيه اذا صور مباشره او صور
للعربيه عفوا خاصه لتصاعد اعمده الدخان مع
استمرار الاشتباكات في المنطقه
الصناعيه بالخرطوم بحري صور المباشره كنا
قد تابعناها بدايه هذه النشره وايضا كذلك
في نشرتنا السابقه لتصاعد اعمده الدخان في
الخرطوم
ومحافظاتها ايضا كذلك واستمرار تصاعد
اعمده الدخان الاشتباكات اذا عادت مره
اخرى لتتجدد في الخرطوم بحري في كافوري
والمنطقه الصناعيه ايضا كذلك كما نقل
مراسل العربيه اذا مشاهدينا
وكذلك كان هناك سماع لذوي انفجارات في
جنوب الخرطوم كذلك
هذا وتتواصل عمليات الاجلاء في ام درمان
حيث قرر الالاف من السودانيين النزوح من
مناطقهم هربا من الاقتتال الدائر فيما
يتجه كثيرون الى بورتسودان من خلال حافلات
لنقل الركاب بات التكلفتها اغلى من
المعتاد بسبب نقص الوقود ويقول الاهالي في
ام درمان ان العائلات تتجه الى مواقف
الحافلات سيرا على الاقدام بسبب عدم توفر
وسائل للنقل مع استمرار الاشتباكات
المسلحه
الرغم ان الخرطوم للولايات فبرده يعني
الحاجه صعبه شديد يعني اول كلمه ماجد خاشش
الشعبي لقيت دفار بعشره
دفار باقل تذكره للبيض بعشر فما بالك يعني
باقي التفاصيل حتكون كيف ولا
الباص هذا سعرها حتكون كيف
يعني الباصات كلها بتمشي بورسودان 12
13 13
اما في بورت سوداني يكافح عشرات الالاف من
الرعايه الاجانب لمغادره السودان في ظل
استمرار القتال حيث تجمعت حشود من
المدنيين في ميناء بوتسودان الذي يعد ملجا
يتوجه اليه الكثيرون على امل مغادره
البلاد عن طريق البحر
السودان عايش في لحظه رعب حقيقيه
يعني انا بتكلم عن جثث في الشوارع
شمينا ريحه الجثث ونحن جايين من الخرطوم
الضرب الغزف يعني بجد السودان في حاله
تعترف حقيقيه
3400 العدد كبير جوا البناء وبرا وعلى
الكورنيش الناس بتنوم في الارض ارامل
اطفال مسنين مرضى بشكل عام احنا قاعدين
هنا في مكان يعني الله يجزاهم الخير
يوفرون اصلا مكان لكن احنا قاعدين في
الارض ويعني اغلب الناس قاعدين في الاراضي
كلنا جايين اماكن بعيده اغلبنا اتيه من
الخرطوم
مباشره من مدينه بورتسودان يلتحق بنا
مراسل العربيه نزار البقداوي نزار مرحبا
بك معي في هذه الساعه يعني تابعنا الاوضاع
في بورسودان قبل قليل الكثافه يبدو ايضا
بان الكثافه لا تتوقف من خلفك نزار كيف
يمكن وصفها الحديث عنها تزايد هذه الاعداد
القادمه الى بورتسودان من المناطق
السودانيه التي تشهد اضطرابات او اشتباكات
نعم نايف يعني هو ليس تزايد بالمعنى
الحرفي بقدر ما هو اكتظاظ لاعداد من
المسافرين والمغادرين لم توفق اوضاعهم بعد
عدم توفيق الاوضاع وعدم اكتمال الاجراءات
المتعلقه بمغادره مئات الاسر السوريه
والاف اليمنيين والسوريين اضيفت اليها
ايضا نايف معضله اخرى قبل يومين وهي مساله
العالقين السودانيين الذين يحملون اقامات
في عقد من الدول العربيه وعدد من هذه
الاقامات الان في طريقها لان تنتهي صلاحيه
هذه الاقامات هذا يستدعي ايضا تدخلا ويضع
عديد السودانيين في معاناه حقيقيه من اجل
الخروج من السودان في ظرف يومين مقبلين
على اطول تعديل تحديد هذه هي الصور
المباشره الان من هذا المركز الرئيسي في
نادي المواني البحريه بمدينه بورسودان هنا
تجري جل عمليات الحصر والتسجيل واستلام
جوازات السفر للسودانيين الراغبين في
مغادره السودان
والسوريين والي اليمنيين ولعدد من رعايه
دول الاجنبيه العربيه والافريقيه
والاوروبيه
لاكثر من ثمانيه ايام شاهدنا ولاحظنا بان
اسرا باطفالها
بنسائها بكبار السن ما زالوا على محيط هذه
المنطقه ينتظرون ان يتم استكمال الاجراءات
المتعلقه بمغادره السودان هذا الامر
استدعى ايضا تحركا رسميا وشعبيا نلاحظ
ايضا قبل يومين بان هيئه الموانئ البحريه
التي تستضيف هذه الاعداد عملت على انشاء
غرفه للطوارئ وهي مستشفى مؤقت تعمل فيه
على التلقي الفحص وتقديم الرعايه الطبيه
لمن يحتاجون من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه وحتى
السودانيين ايضا هنالك جمعيات تطوعيه
شبابيه تقدم الماء البارد وتقدم الطعام
للسوريين ولليمنيين الذين تقطعت بهما
السبل هم يتحدثون عن عن قصص حزينه وقصص
مرعبه في طريقهم من الخرطوم الى مدينه
وكثير منه فقد ماله وفقد كل مقتنياته هم
الان يطالبون ويناشدون السلطات السوريه
والحكومه
السودانيه وايضا السلطات في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه التي تنسق وتساعد وتساهم
مع عدد من البعثات بالاستعجال في استكمال
اجراءاتهم ويقولون بانه اذا كان من مشكله
فيمكن للاسر يمكن لكبار السن يمكن للنساء
ان تكون لهم الاولويه في عمليه الاجلاء
وبقيه الشباب يمكن ان يظلوا هنا في مدينه
بورسودان الى ان تترتب الاوضاع ويتسنى لهم
مغادره السودان خلال الايام المقبله اشكرك
جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات والصوره
من بورتودان مراسل العربيه نزار البداوي
وافادت مصادر للعربيه ان القاهره تنسق مع
الجيش السوداني لاجلاء المصريين العالقين
بقاعده وادي سيدنا وتشير تقديرات وفقا
لمراسل العربيه الى دخول نحو خمسه عشر الف
سوداني الى مصر عبر المنافذ البريه فيما
يصل السودانيون الذين قرروا الفرار من
النزاع عن طريق منفذ قسطل البري لتكون
مدينه ابو سمبل اولى محطات استقبالهم
اهالي المدينه حرصوا على تقديم كافه انواع
المساعده للناجحين نتابع
عن طريق نهر النيل يصل النازحون
السودانيون الى مدينه ابو سمبل بعد عبورهم
من بعبر قسطنب البري الوجوه المرهقه من
عناء الرحله الطويله تبتسم اخيرا مع
استقبال اهالي اخر مدينه على الحدود
المصريه الجنوبيه السكان يتجمعون حاملين
ما تيسر من طعام وشراب لتقديمه لاهالي
السودان قبل استئناف رحلتهم الى مدينه
اسوان احنا طبعا لازم نقف جنب اشقائنا
السودانيين في الازمه اللي هم فيها واحنا
عملنا المبادره دي مع شباب القريه عندنا
اهل البلد يعني يعني الخدمه اللي قدموها
لنا ما حسستني انه ليس مازلنا في السودان
يعني بعض القادمين لا يملكون الاموال
اللازمه لاستكمال الرحله احدى المجموعات
النازحه توجهت الى وسط المدينه لتفاجا برد
فعل الاهالي الذين قاموا بجمع المساعدات
المطلوبه
والله انا يعني
الكرم ولقينا الضيافه ولقينا منهم والله
كل خير يعني احنا نقوتهم فوق راسنا مع بعض
وجبنا
اللبن للاطفال وببرونها للاطفال
وبامبرز للاطفال جبناهم مستشفى ابو سمبل
يعمل على قدم الوثائق لاستقبال النازحين
موفرين لهم ما يحتاجونه من دواء واسعافات
من كل الهيئات الصحيه سواء تامين شامل
سواء وزاره الصحه حتى برضو لقينا برضو
مساعدات من جهات تانيه ففضل الله محدش
مقصر يعني
ورغم اصراري اغلب من ياتون الى ابو سمبل
لاستكمال رحلاتهم لمدينه اسوان فان
مستقبليهم يصرون على دعوتهم للمبيت في
بيوتهم للراحه من وعثاء السفر الطويل سكان
ابو سمبل يؤكدون دائما بان السودان يمثل
لهم امتدادا ليس جغرافيا فقط ولكن انسانيا
ايضا كلمات وشعارات برهنه الاحداث على مدى
مصداقيتها احمد عثمان العربيه من مدينه
ابو سمبل محافظه اسوان
اذا
مشاهدينا في متابعه ايضا للشان
السوداني
نتابع هذه الصور الان
لتصاعد اعمده الدخان والتي كما ذكرنا
بانها لا تزال مستمره ومتصاعده في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم ومن اسوان جنوب مصر
ينضم الينا المحلل السياسي السوداني عمار
عوض سيد عمار مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه
اريد ان ابدا معك بهذه التصريحات اللافته
للمبعوثه الاممي في السودان يقول بان
الجيش والدعم السريع وفقاع على ارسال
مندوبين للتفاوض ما الذي يعني هذا المنعرج
اليوم في الازمه السودانيه هل يمكن القول
بان الحلول الدبلوماسيه التفاوض اصبح
المهم والاهم لكل الاطراف الان
السيد عمار هل تسمعوني
مرحبا بك معي هل سمعت السؤال ام اعيده
عليك
نعم انا سمعت السؤال وهذا ما كنت اريد ان
اقوله في البدايه دعونا نتقدم بالشكر
الكبير نحن الان في مدينه اسوان
للحكومه المصريه لما قدمته من استقبال ومن
دعم للسودانيين وللسلطات السودانيه في نفس
الوقت نتقدم ايضا بشكر كبير لحكومه جلاله
خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان ابن عبد العزيز وعلى الجهود التي
قاموا بها
نعم هنالك الان نحن في مجموعه سوداني
يونايتد التي تعمل مع مختلف الاطراف
لمساعدتهم
لانهاء هذه الحرب من المتوقع ان تكون
هنالك لقاء
للامانه هذا اللقاء الذي سيعقد في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في مدينه جده حسب ما
حصلنا عليه من معلومات حصل مع علي حصلنا
عليه من وعودات بانه سيختصر في البدايه
على لقاء يتعلق
الامر الذي يتعلق بالهدنه بان تكون هدنه
قادره لان تصمت لفترات طويله ان يتم وقفي
للدخول في اجراءات لوقف اطلاق نار دائم
كما تعلمون كانت هذه المحادثات او على قله
تقدير دعونا نسميها اللقاءات حتى نكون
دقيقين في الالفاظ هذه اللقاءات التي كان
هنالك كانت تتنازعها
الجمله من الدول بما في ذلك منظمه ايجاد
وكانت هنالك اقتراحات ان تتم فيه جوبا
كانت هنالك اقتراحات ان تتم في جزر القمر
لكن الان الراجح حتى هذه اللحظه التي
نتحدث فيها سيكون هذا اللقاء لممثل من
الجيش وممثل من الدعم السريع في مدينه جده
عاصمه المنطقه الغربيه
يكون هنالك ايضا حضور يتوقع ان يكون هنالك
حضور عربي يتوقع ان يكون هناك حضور دولي
يتوقع ايضا ان تجري هذه هذه اللقاءات ولا
نسميها محادثات
لتمكين اجراءات الهدنه
يعني نحن نحن نتحدث فقط الان في هذه
المحادثات او انت التي تسميها يعني ربما
حوارات بين طرفي هذه الازمه هي فقط تتعلق
بشان تثبيت الهدنه او تمديد امد هذه
الهدنه التي لم تصمد اصلا
نعم المطلوب
هو من ان نتوقع ان يناقشه يناقشه الممثلين
من الاطراف هو تثبيت الاجراءات الهدنه كما
تعلم انت المعارك التي تدور التي نسمعها
نحن منذ ان عبرنا الحدود ودخلنا جمهوريه
مصر الذين نتحدث معهم في الخرطوم نحن نعلم
جيدا ان الاطراف المتصارعه وتحديدا نحن
نتحدث عن قوات الدعم السريعيه تحاول
ان ان تعيد موضعها كما يقال في اللغه
العسكريه او كما يقال في لغه العسكريين
بحيث انها محافظ على اراضي جديده تحافظ
على المناطق التي كانت موجوده فيها في
السابق لذلك نحن وبالتالي نتوقع هنا ان
تستمر هذه الاشتباكات حتى الجلوس طرفي هذه
الازمه على طاوله الحوار سواء على طاوله
امميه او طويله يعني تجمع المبعوثه الاممي
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه نعم او لو حتى
كانت في اي بلد اخر يعني
نعم ما يحدث هو ان في سابق في الايام
الماضيه قبل ان نخرج من الخرطوم كان هنالك
الجيش السوداني حطم المعسكرات التي تتبع
لقوات الدعم السريع اذا كانت في مناطق
كالوري جبل شركات اذا كان في مناطق الجبل
اولياء اذا كان في مناطق جري في مناطق
بحري غيره قوات الدعم السريع كانت تنتشر
داخل الاحياء داخل المدن بالتالي كانت
تكسر منها تلك التفلتات تكثر منها ما يعرف
ما يمكن ان يسمى في اللغه الحروب بسياسه
الارض المحروقه اي انها تحاول ان يعني
تتجول داخل المدن تتحاول تحاول ان ليس
لديها مكان حتى عندما يتم تثبيت الهدنه
وتثبيت وقف اطلاق النار هي ليس لديها مكان
هي موجوده فيه الاماكن اللي هي موجوده
فيها كانت موجوده فيها في السابق لانها
كانت شريكه او لانها كانت جزء دعنا نقول
ذلك كانت جزء من القوات النظاميه في
السودان بالتالي كان طبيعيا ان تكون
متواجده في منطقه القياده العامه كانت
طبيعيا ان تكون متواجده في الاذاعه
والتلفزيون كان طبيعيا لكن كمعسكرات على
الارض هي ليس لديها وجوديه تحاول
الانضمام نسمع من الذين يعملون معنا في في
اطفاء نار هذه الحرب هي تتحاول ان تتمركز
في مناطق حيويه مثل الجسور لذلك ان كنتم
ان كنتم سيد عمار قد حصلتم ربما على
معلومات اوليه يعني من خلال مصادركم حول
هذه
المحادثات او الحوارات التي ستجري بين
طرفي الازمه هل هناك اي شروط مسبقه من
طرفي هذه الازمه للجلوس على طاوله التفاوض
سؤال ايضا حتى كذلك ما هي المعوقات حتى
التي يعني يمكن ان تحد من اقناع الطرفي
هذه الازمه بانهاء
العنف كما قال السيد فولكربريتس
هنالك مشكله اساسيه بالنسبه
لراني الذي يخوض هو يتحدث الان البيان
الذي صدر منه بانه لن تعود عقارب الساعه
للوراء بمعنى انه لن يتم هو لا ان يعود
القوات الدعم السريع مره اخرى هو يتحدث في
بيانه بالنسبه لنا نحن كمراقبين نعمل
مونتري فيه مثل هذه الاشياء
[موسيقى]
ومع الاقل تقدير في الوقت الراهن او ان
هذه هي السقوفات التي يتحركون حولها
السقوفات التي يتحركون
حول عندما يقولون لن
تعود ذلك انه
يعني هنالك مجال لمشاركه سياسيه لحوارات
سياسيه لوضع سياسي مميز لقوات الدعم
السريع هذا مفهوم لن تعود عقارب الساعه
للوراء ايضا في الفقره الاخيره التي
يتحدثون فيها على ان لن يكون هنالك مجال
للتشوهات التي اوجدها النظام البيت طبعا
نحن نعلم جميعا ان النظام الاسلامي او
نظام عمر البشير هو الذي انشا قوات هذه
قوات الدعم السريعي هذه لذلك هم يشيرون
نعم
لا كنت اقول معلوم يعني معلومه يعني
معروفه هذه المعلومه يعني ايوه نعم لذلكم
يقولون لن نسمح نحن نفهم كمراقبين ماذا
يعني ذلك عندما يقولون لن يكون هنالك مجال
للتشوهات التي اوجد الجيشين في الفتره
الماضيه ذلك يعني ان هذا هو السقف الذي
دونه خلف الغتاد بالنسبه لهم ووضحوه بانهم
يريدون ان اي لقاءات دعنا نكرر هي ليست
محادثات هي ليست مفاوضات هي لقاء لقاء
فيما يتعلق قبل ان نختم معك سيدي عمار انا
ما تبقى لدي الكثير من الوقت هذا هذه
بالنسبه للسقوفات الجيش السوداني بالنسبه
للطرف الاخر الدعم السريع هل من شروط من
سقوفات له ايضا هو الاخر لانه طرف في هذه
الازمه
نعم لم
[تصفيق]
يصدر معينه لديه لانه هو اصلا الدعم
السريع كان دائما يتحدث على انه يجب انه
سيخرج من الحياه
السياسيه غير لكن اتوقع اتوقع انه يكون
لديهم ما يمكن ان يقال عليه سقوفات مثل
التي تحدثنا حولها فيما يتعلق بالعوده
لمسار الاطار السياسي ايضا ان يقول لديهم
ما يتعلق
الطريقه
تتدمج ايضا ما يتعلق بالمسائل المتعلقه بك
تحديد الجهه التي اجعلت هذه الحرب هذا كان
يتحدث مستشارينهم عندما يكون ما في
الخرطوم كان يتحدثوا عن هذه الاشياء بشكل
كثير لكن المهم بالنسبه لنا كمراقبين
ولاخوتنا في الاعلام العربي حتى لا من جر
في مشكله الذي يحدث لقاء وليس هو محادثات
ليس هو حوار ليس هو
التفاوض
نحن نوصف المفاوضات طبقا لما قاله المبعوث
الاممي سيد فولكر بيريتس بانها مفاوضات
بين طرفي هذه
الازمه وارسال مندوبين ايضا حتى للتفاوض
استخدم هذا المصطلح لم يستخدم اي مصطلح
اخر كما ذكرت سيد عمار على كل حال انا
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من اسوان جنوب مصر انضم
الينا المحلل السياسي السوداني عماره شكرا
جزيلا لك
بين عمليات النزوح والاجلاء هناك قصص
كثيره يعيشها المتجهون من الخرطوم الى
المعابر حيث تعرض العديد منهم خلال رحله
الطريق لقطاع طرق وعمليات نهب واستغلال من
تجار الحرب نتابع
مسيره شاقه رحله لجوء بدات من هنا من
سوريا الى السودان لجا الى الخرطوم قبل
سنوات هربا من الحرب لينتهي به الحال في
مواجهه حرب اخرى
عيسى شاب سوري استقر به الحال بين اهالي
ولايه كسلا تبعد 700 كم عن معارك الخرطوم
لكن قبل وصوله الى مدينه حلفا عاش قصه
نزوح مضطربه
المعارك كانت على مرمى حجر منه قرر العوده
الى سوريا عبر رحلات اجلاء من بورتسودان
لكن ما كان ينتظره اسوء
الى السعوديه ومن ثم الى سوريا
او عرف في الشارع
طلعت علي عصابه
مئات الالاف يرغبون بالعوده لكن الطريق
الى المعابر ان لم تكن مدروسه امنيا
محفوفه بقطاع الطرق او مفخخه بتجار حرب
تجار بات لا ينقلون النازحين الا بالاف
الدولارات ما جعلهم غنيمه لعمليات نهب لا
تصدها هدى غذاء السالم العربيه
وفي متابعه لجهود السعوديه في عمليات
الاجلاء المستمره فدى مراسل العربيه بوصول
سفينه حربيه امريكيه تقل 308 اشخاص من سته
عشره جنسيه قادمه من السودان الى ميناء
جده الاسلامي واضاف مراسل العربيه ان جده
استقبلت 26 سفينه اجلاء قادمه من السودان
حتى الان بالاضافه الى 49 رحله اجلاء جويه
من بورتودان وصلت الى جدات تقل اكثر من
200 شخص كما ستغادر طائره عسكريه هنديه من
جده الى السودان لاجلاء 140 شخصا
[موسيقى]
وفي متابعه للاوضاع الطبيه قال المسؤول
الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر السوداني اسامه
ابو بكر في تصريحاته للعربيه قال ان
التقدير تشير لوجود نحو 500 جثه لقتل
الاشتباكات واضاف ان جثامين قتل
الاشتباكات تمثل مشكله كبرى
ما نحتاج
للمعينات الطبيه بالذات مختلف المعينات
الطبيه والمستلزمات الطبيه والشحنه
القادمه من اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
هي فيها كل المستلزمات الطبيه حسب
الاولويات المطروحه بحكم انه اللجنه
الدوليه الخريطه لاحمد عندها جثه قائمه
منذ عشرات السنين في السودان ونعمل مع بعض
سويا لذلك كل الاشياء الجايه في الشحنه دي
هي اشياء عندها اولويه طبعا الشحنه يعني
هي 8 طن او 8000 كيلو يعني وبالتالي حتحدث
انفراج كبير جدا
ابو بكر قال ايضا للعربيه ان المساعدات
الطبيه المرسله من الصليب الاحمر تمثل
انفراجه كبيره للازمه الصحيه في السودان
التي تاثرت بشكل كبير بسبب الاقتتال
الدائري بين قوه الجيش والدعم السريع
المساعدات الحتجي من برنامج الوزاره
العالمي او اي من المؤسسات العالميه اكيد
حتستفيد منها اللي هيستفيد منها المواطنين
وضحايا النزاع المسلح ودائما نحن عندنا
الشراكات مع كل هذه المنظمات التابعه
للامم المتحده وغيرها في انه هي بتعتمد
على الهلال الاحمر بالذات في توزيع
المساعدات سواء كانت مساعده صحيه او
انسانيه على مستوى السودان فضلا عن
الخرطوم لانه الهلال الاحمر السوداني
يعتمد في عمله اساسا على متطوعين متخصصين
في مجالات مختلفه يبلغ عددهم قريب النصف
مليون متطوع في جميع انحاء السودان
السودان نظام الرعايه الصحيه على وشك
الانهيار الصحه العالميه اكدت وقوع 26
هجوما على مرافق الرعايه الصحيه من دون
اندلاع الصراع بالسودان
وتقول ان المستشفيات تعرضت للقصف واغلق
سلساها في الخرطوم نقابه اطباء السودان
حذرت من الانهيار الكامل للنظام الرعايه
الصحيه
الصليب الاحمر العاملون في مجال الرعايه
الصحيه في السودان يفعلون المستحيل يعتنون
بالجرحى بدون ماء وكهرباء وامدادات طبيه
اساسيه
منظمات غير حكوميه تبذل جهودا لانقاذ
القطاع الصحي في السودان في ظل المعارك
المتواصله
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود قالت انها تبرعت
بمستلزمات طبيه لثلاثه مستشفيات في
الخرطوم
ومن الصليب الاحمر وصلت اول شحنه من
الامدادات الطبيه الى السودان
وطائره ثانيه ستنقل امدادات طبيه اضافيه
وموظفين في مجال الطوارئ
وفي متابعه لجهود السعوديه في عمليات
الاجلاء المستمره افاد مراسل العربيه
باصول سفينه حربيه امريكيه تقل 108 اشخاص
من سته عشرات جنسيه قادمه من السودان الى
ميناء جده الاسلامي واضاف ان جده استقبلت
26 سفينه اجلاء قادمه من السودان حتى الان
بالاضافه الى 49 رحله اجلاء جويه من
بورتسودان وصلت الى جده تقل اكثر من 2200
شخص كما ستغادر طائره عسكريه هنديه من جده
الى السودان لاجلاء 140 شخصا
مع تفاقم الازمات
الصحيه في السودان زادت المخاوف من كارثه
كبيره في توفير الدواء مع دخول الاشتباكات
بين قوات الجيش والدعم السريع اسبوعها
الثالث نتابع
صيدليات مغلقه ورفوف ادويه شبه فارغه هذه
حصيله نحو اسبوعين من الاشتباكات يضاف لها
عمليات نهب واسعه طالت صيدليات ومخازن
ادويه في العاصمه السودانيه هنا في مدينه
ام درمان يستمر اغلاق عدد كبير من
الصيدليات منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات في ظل
تحذيرات من تفاقم الازمه الصحيه على مستوى
البلاد حاليا الادويه
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك يا ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه اللي بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي
او الادويه التاثير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
الناس طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في الحي
الادويه دي اساسا ما متوفره في الظروف
العاديه فيها شح والان المشكله بقت اكبر
تهدد الازمه الحاليه صحه الكبار والصغار
على حد سواء فاسعار الادويه بارتفاع مستمر
فيما اصنافها المتوفره بانخفاض مقلق وجد
الاحداث الدوحه من سنين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن او لدى تفتشوا ما خلا
اي حته فتج عشان
ما خلينا صيدليه ما لقينا ما خلينا حته ما
لقينا وحتى عربيه ذاته يتحركوا بها عشان
يجيبوا لي الدواء ما في بنزين ما في هناك
طريقه نمرق من البلد عشان نمشي نفتش
الدواء نجيبه اما بالنسبه للمستشفيات فلا
يزال القليل منها الذي يعمل في الخرطوم
يعاني نقصا حادا في الادويه والمستلزمات
العلاجيه الاخرى خاصه المتعلقه بالجرحى
والمحاليل الوريديه ما يفاقم من معاناه
المرضى مع استمرار توقف الامداد الدوائي
الحكومي نور الحصني العربيه
في هذه الاثناء اعلن برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي عن استئناف انشطته في السودان
لتقديم المساعدات العاجله في ظل تدهور
الوضع الانساني في البلاد من جهتها قلت
المديره التنفيذيه للبرنامج
على حسابها في تويتر ان الازمه الحاليه في
السودان تدفع الملايين الى هويه الجوع ادى
لرفع التعليق المؤقت لبرنامج الاغذيه
العالمي في السودان وفي منتصف ابريل
الماضي قال البرنامج انه اوقف مؤقتا جميع
انشطته في السودان بعدما اقتل ثلاثه من
موظفي في اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع
هذا هو يواجه ثلث سكان السودان البالغ
اعدادهم حوالي 45 مليون نسمه ازمه جوع
متصاعده ما دفع برنامج الاغذيه العالمي
لوصف الوضع الانساني في البلاد بالكارثي
معاناه على معاناه تجثم على قلوب
السودانيين اما كساد يؤرق محالهم التجاريه
او شبح جوع يلوح في الافق السودان يشكو
ازمه تتراكم عليها ازمات سابقه متداخله
الوضع الانساني كارثي او كما وصفه الامين
العام للامم المتحده بلغ نقطه الانهيار
السودان اسره على السلطه في السودان لا
يعرض مستقبل هذا البلد للخطر فحسب انه
يضيء فتيلا يمكن ان ينفجر عبر الحدود
ويسبب معاناه هائله لسنوات ويعيد التنميه
الى الوراء لعقود
صراع فاقم معاناه المدنيين الساعين وراء
لقمه العيش تقرير اممي سابق اوضح ان ثلث
السكان اصلا كانوا يعيشون على المساعدات
الانسانيه قبل اندلاع الصراع ووفق برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي يواجه 15 مليون شخص
انعداما حادا في الامن الغذائي ومع اندلاع
الصراع باتت ولايات السودان الثمانيه عشره
تحت رحمه مساعدات قد تتوقف بسبب اغلاق
ممرات الاغاثه حيث تمثل دارفور التحدي
الاكبر من الناحيه الانسانيه بحسب
المنظمات الامميه وتليها عده ولايات هي
الاكثر تضررا من النزاع والتدهور
الاقتصادي كالخرطوم وكسلا والنيل الابيض
وجنوب كردفان لا طعام لملايين الاطفال
تصريح سبق صراع السلطه لمسؤوله الاتصال في
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في السودان ومع
اول مواجهات اندلعت فان ارقام الذين
سينامون جائعين قد تتضاعف محمد السيف
العربيه
[موسيقى]
هذه وقفه مع ابرز الاخبار الدوليه في
فرنسا تستعد النقابات لاحياء يوم تاريخي
لعيد العمال تتوقعوا نزول ما يصل الى
مليون ونصف المليون شخص الى الشوارع
لمواصله الاحتجاج رفضا لقانون الاصلاح
اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي اقره الرئيس
ايمانويل ماكرون وقال الامين العام
للاتحاد الديمقراطي الفرنسي للعمل انهم
يتوقعون مشاركه مئات الالاف من المتظاهرين
موضحا ان النقابات اعدت 300 نقطه تجمع في
مختلف انحاء البلاد لاحياء عيد الاول من
مايو من جههها تتوقع السلطات نزول نحو 650
الف متظاهر من ضمنهم ما بين 80 الى 100
الف في باريس وحدها كما اكدت ان اثني عشر
الف عنصر من الشرطه سينتشرون لضمان الامن
بنا مدير مكتب العربيه في باريس حسين
قنيبر حسين مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره
يبدو ان الاعداد يعني زادت كثافتها في
العاصمه باريس لكن هل بدات المظاهرات بشكل
فعلي الان ام هذه نقطه من نقاط التجمع
التي اعلنت عنها النقابات حسين
هذه نقطه التجمع الرئيسيه في التظاهره
المركزيه التي ستجري التي بدات هنا في
باريس طبعا هناك تظاهرات اخرى في كل من
اليوم ومارسيليا ومونبوليا ونيس وكان
وتلوز وايضا في ليل واستراسبور وكلارمون
وكذلك في رن ونوت وبوردو ومدن اخرى كثيره
في فرنسا تريد ان نقابات رغم قرار المجلس
الدستوري في الرابع عشر من الشهر الماضي
والذي اعتبر ان البنود الرئيسيه في قانون
رفع سن التقاعد ليست مخالفه للدستور مع
ذلك تريد النقابات ان تحاول اسقاط قانون
رفع سن التقاعد في الشارع وهذا ما يعتبره
مراقبون امرا مستبعدا اترك الكلمه
الاسطوره كما تشاهد اعداد كبيره هنا في
ساحه الجمهوريه لبلاس دولاريك حيث تنطلق
التظاهره بعد دقائق من نحو ساحه لناسيون
ساحه الامه 12 الف عنصر امن بين شرطي
ودركي يتولون المواكبه الامنيه ل 300 موكب
احتجاجي عبر فرنسا من بينهم خمسه الاف في
باريس وحدها تتوقع النقابات مشاركه ما
يزيد عن المليون شخص ما بين المليون
ومليون ونصف المليون في التظاهرات اليوم
بينما تقول وزاره الداخليه مذكره
للاستخبارات الداخليه تتوقع ان يشارك
حوالي 600 الف شخص في التظاهرات عبر فرنسا
من بينهم ما بين 80 الفا ما بين ثمانين
الف ومئه الف في باريس وحدها معي هنا
للاجابه على اسئلتنا السيده تشارك في هذه
التظاهرات بونجور
دسات
جوغونس
موبيليزاسيون
اقول لها 17 يوما بعد قرار المجلس
الدستوري تحرككم ما يزال مستمرا لم يمسه
شيء اشرحي لنا ذلك
يجب ان نعرف ان 80% من الفرنسيين يعترضون
على قرار المجلس الدستوري
و70% منهم لا يريدون رفع سن التقاعد بقوه
الالماني
اقول لها لماذا تعترضون على رفع سن
التقاعد علما انه في المانيا 66 عاما في
ايطاليا 67 عاما وفي اسبانيا 56 عاما
سن التقاعد في الدول الاوروبيه هو اكثر
مما هو في فرنسا ندخل
نحن نقول ان هناك حلول اخرى لتمويل العجز
في صندوق التقاعد والبالغ 17 مليار يورو
كما تقول الحكومه الرئيس يقترح علينا حلا
واحدا هو ان يعمل الفرنسيون تقصد عامين
اضافيين كحل وحيد ونحن نرى ان تمت حلولا
اخرى لتمويل نظام التقاعد
هذا بعض من الصوره هنا اترك الكاميرا
تتحرك مجددا نحو الاعداد الكبيره من
المتظاهرين الذين يواصلون التدفق الى ساحه
الجمهوريه قبل ان ينطلقوا الى ساحه الامه
التظاهره ستتواصل التظاهرات عفوا هنا في
باريس حتى الساعه السابعه مساء بالتوقيت
المحلي وزير العمل اوليفيا قال ان الحكومه
ستوجه دعوات للنقبات كي تجري حوارا معها
النقابات التي ما زالت موحده حتى الان قد
لا تبقى كذلك لان ثمه اتجاها لدى بعضها
خصوصا نقابه
الفرنسيه
للعمل لديها اتجاه الى القبول بدعوه
الحكومه للحوار فيما نقابه سيجيت
الكونفدراليه العامه للعمل تقول انها لم
تتخذ قرانا بعد بالموافقه على الحوار مع
الحكومه شكرا جزيل على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل لك ايضا من باريس مدير مكتب
العربيه هناك حسين خنيبر شكرا لك
كشف قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه ان
الهجمات المضاده الاوكرانيه طردت قوات
الروسيه من بعض المواقع في باقي البلاد
لكن رغم ذلك اشار الى ان الوضع لا يزال
صعبا واكد ان وحدات روسيه جديده تشمل
مظاليين ومقاتلين ايضا يتم الدفع بهم مع
استمرار المعركه في باخمت القائد
الاوكراني اضاف ايضا ان روسيا غير قادره
على السيطره على مدينه باكمت استمرار
الحرب لشهور
بعد ان دعم مسؤول اوكرانيون المدنيين الى
البقاء في الملاجئ مع اطلاق سفارات
الانذار لنحو ثلاث ساعات من ساعات الصباح
الاولى اكد القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
ان دفاعاتهم اسقطت 15 صاروخا الروسيه من
اصل 18 موضحا ايضا ان كل الصواريخ الروسيه
التي حاولت استهداف كييف تم التصدي لها
ولا اصابات وقعت اثرها حسب المعلومات
الاوليه كما افادت وسائل اعلام اوكرانيه
عن وقوع انفجارات اخرى في دنيبرو
بيتروفيسكو ومناطق فيسومي
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه استهداف عده
مواقع لمدفعيه الجيش الاوكراني في دانيتس
واكد المتحدث باسم الدفاع الروسيه ان
القوات الروسيه قامت بشن غارات على ثلاثه
مواقع لمدفعيه الجيش الاوكراني مضيفا ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تكبدت خسائر بشريه وصلت
الى 60 شخصا
وفي الاثناء تسبب انفجار عبوه ناسفه في
منطقه اونشا بمقاطعه بريانسكا الروسيه الى
خروج قطار عن مساره ويعد الحادث واحدا من
الهجمات التي تشهدها مقاطعه بريانسك
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا وذكر حاكم مقاطعه
برينس ان الانفجار وما اعقبه من خروج قطار
عن مساره لم يسفر عن وقوع اي اصابات
بحث وزير الخارجيه الاردني ايمن الصفدي مع
نظيره السوري فيصل المقداد الجهود
المبذوله لاطلاق دور عربي قيادي للتوصل
لحل سياسي للازمه السوريه وذكرت الخارجيه
الاردنيه ان لقاء الوزيرين الذي بحثا في
عده قضايا ثنائيه منها امن الحدود ومكافحه
تهريب المخدرات جاء قبيل انطلاق اعمال
اجتماع عمان التشوري الذي تستضيفه الاردن
ويشارك فيه وزراء خارجيه السعوديه وسوريا
والعراق ومصر
تجمع عشرات الاف الاتراك في الساحات
العامه في تجمعات انتخابيه قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والتشريعيه منتصف مايو وجمع كل
من الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ومنافسه
الابرز كما
حشودا ضخمه وتوعد كل منهما الاخر بالهزيمه
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
حشد وحشد المقابل في تركيا قبل اسبوعين
على الرابع عشر من مايو الذي ربما يكون
موعد الحسم في الانتخابات الرئاسيه الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان كان استانف السبت حملته
الانتخابيه ونشاطه العامه بعد وعكه صحيه
المت به الاسبوع الماضي حتى في انقره
مواطنيه ممن لم يحسموا خيرهم بعد على
التصويت لصالحه كما توعد اردوغان مرشح
المعارضه وقال امام الالاف من مؤيديه في
العاصمه ان الشعب التركيه سيخرج مرشح
المعارضه من الحياه السياسيه وعدد لسكان
انقره ما قال انها انجازاته انقره باتت
عاصمه للصناعات الدفاعيه بفضل الاستثمارات
الحكوميه خلال العقدين الماضيين عملنا على
تطوير وتنميه انقره ورفع مستوى الرفاهيه
فيها على مدى عقدين شانها شان كفه مدن
تركيا الاخرى
غرب البلاد وفي مدينه ازمير معقل المعارضه
شدد زعيم ومرشح المعارضه كمال كالجدار
اوغلو على ان الانتخابات خطوه على طريق
اعاده بناء الديمقراطيه التركيه متعهدا
باعاده الاستقرار للبلاد باصواتكم سنخرج
تركيا من هذا الوضع في عهد لن يكون هناك
تمييز ساحتضن 85 مليون تركي سواء صوتوا لي
ام لا يمكن للجميع التاكد من ان كمال
سيكون الى جانبكم جميعا
يؤكدان على امكانيه الفوز من الدوره
الاولى الا ان التوقعات تشير الى ترجيح
حسم اسم الرئيس عبر دوره اقتراع ثانيه
تقام في 28 من مايو حسن جولد العربيه
وثقت مقاطع فيديو مشاهد للاعصار الذي ضرب
ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه وتسبب بانقطاع
الكهرباء عن حوالي 4000 شخص وكان من اكثر
المقاطع لفتا للانتباه ما نقله شهود عيان
قالوا ان احدى المركبات انقلبت وتحطمت على
الرصيف وتطاير ركامها امامهم
شكرا لكم على كرمي ولطف المتابعه نهايه
هذه الساعه الاخباريه تغطيه اخبار السودان
مستمره على راس الساعه مع الزميل طالب
كنعاني طالب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات